one of the worst things i think that
have happened during these three and a
half years
is that all the children who have looked
to see
what a leader looks like have seen
donald trump
they've heard his language they've heard
his meanness
they've heard his bullying and that's
who they've
learned to accept as their president we
have to end that
we need a president like joe biden who's
going to treat people with respect
with empathy to deal with racial in in
inequities
and to be able to make a difference in
this world
joe biden has the experience and wisdom
that we need at this moment
now turn the program over to lynn carey
a retired nurse and nursing professor
from washington
county
thank you justice it is really wonderful
to be here today
with all of you and with of course dr
biden
my family jill
my family understands the economic
consequences of health insurance
in 2004 i was diagnosed
with a rare lung disease i saw my doctor
because i was short of breath
i thought i would leave his office with
a prescription for an inhaler
instead i left with a prescription for
oxygen
24 7 and a diagnosis that changed my
life
i was on oxygen every day all day
i was on very expensive medications
i needed to be monitored by my
pulmonologist
every three months and i needed
expensive procedures like heart
catheterizations
i had to stop working and when you stop
working
we all know what happens right what do
you lose
your health insurance i lost my health
insurance
i was able to go on my husband's plan
and then he lost his job
so we lost our insurance again
i know what it feels like to be sitting
across the table
when someone tells you that you do not
qualify for insurance
because you have a pre-existing
condition we cannot go back
fortunately he did find a job shortly
after
and i was able to get on his plan they
could not deny me
because of the aca actually dr biden
jill i first met you eight years ago
during the obama biden chem re-election
campaign
i was on oxygen and i have a picture and
for some reason
you look the same but
i don't look that same
but i remember your kindness and concern
as we talked well as you can see i don't
need oxygen to talk with you today
on may 13th
i may press audio check one two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten nine eight
seven six five four three two
one
press audio check one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
press audio check one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten nine
eight seven six five four three
two one
thank you lynn and it's it's wonderful
to see you again my gosh
you know as a nursing educator and a
transplant survivor
you know our health care system better
than anyone wow you have quite a story
and you've seen how innovation can save
lives and
the quality of care doesn't mean much if
you if you can't afford it right
so once again i'm so grateful for your
sharing your
incredible story and i thank you for
your tireless efforts
for making sure that all americans get
the health care that they need
amy and maggie thank you so much for
hosting us today
in your beautiful house and your
beautiful land
with your beautiful animals
so um i'm so glad to be here in
waukesha i said that right right okay
especially uh to be here in person after
so many i've done
so many virtual events in your state
but i i'd like to start with um a
personal story of my own
so as many of you know i've taught um
for the last 10 years i've taught
writing
at northern virginia community college
but i've been a teacher for forever for
36 years
and um a few a few years ago
i had to tell my students that i would
miss the next class for
uh personal reasons and
so my students have a lot of shining
qualities but
boundaries are not one of them so they
immediately began shouting to me dr b
dr b where are you going well my sister
jan was having a stem cell transplant
the first of her cancer treatments and
she would be isolated in a hospital room
for
over six weeks and i tried to explain
that to my class with as much composure
as i could muster
but as i tried to tell them you know the
words caught in my throat
and so i turned around and i was in my
classroom and i
tried i faced the whiteboard you know
hoping to gain
my composure and as i
turned back around my entire class
was lined up and they gave me a hug
one by one and that
act of kindness that act of community
gave me the strength to keep going
and it saved me in a time when i didn't
even realize how much i was struggling
and in a way that active community saved
my sister
jan too you know she has built her
career
as a waitress and when she got sick
believe me she didn't have the money
and she didn't have the insurance to
cover her treatments
it was only because of the affordable
care act that she was able to find
a plan that she could afford and it was
that
law that made it possible for her to get
covered
even though she had a pre-existing
condition
so it's easy to take for granted just
how much
changed when we passed the aca
so 20 million people got covered
it's amazing to think of that including
more than two wisconsinites
wisconsin wisconsinites i don't think i
ever said that word before
so pre-existing conditions
got covered you know it's not an
exaggeration to say that this
law saved my sister's life
and we all know that the ability to take
care of our health
is the foundation of a good life i mean
we all agree with that
but these last few months have shown us
that it's more than that too
our health is the foundation of our
communities and our economy
and gosh this pandemic
has done so much damage
some of it can be measured the over
over 200 000 american
lives lost millions who have
contracted this disease and may now
and because of it now have a
pre-existing condition
the more than 10 million workers
who are jobless but in other ways
the damage can't be measured the lost
time with our loved ones the mental toll
of
isolation and anxiety the shattered
hearts
of every family that is grieving
a loved one and it didn't
have to be this way i mean that's
that's what's so unbelievable it didn't
have to be this way
and at almost every turn
this administration has not only
failed to prevent and mitigate the
destruction around us
they've made it worse as the pandemic
rages
president trump is attacking the health
care
coverage that millions of americans rely
on
and trying to eliminate the protections
for people with
pre-existing conditions
he's hoping to get rid of the law that
protects them
i mean for all of us i mean it just we
it's
unbelievable still amid the chaos and
the grief
we also have so many stories of courage
and resistance
and resilience health care workers
going above and beyond to care for their
patients
educators driving to neighborhoods to
create hot spots
for kids who don't have wi-fi
people donating food at food banks and
in order for others to keep safe it's
amazing
the food insecurity that we've seen in
this country
and the and across this country people
of all walks of life
are putting their shoulders back and
fighting for each other
we haven't given up we just
need leadership worthy of our
nation worthy of all of you
and joe is the only candidate in this
race with the
plan to recover from this pandemic
he's going to provide clear
evidence-based
yes he believes in science national
guidance for businesses
schools and individuals created by
public health experts and he's going to
make sure that our schools and our child
care centers
have the resources that they need to be
safe
so that our kids can go back to school
and we all can go back to work
and he's going to ensure that all
americans
have access like we said you know to
free
testing free treatments and
and when that vaccine comes out
so that we can protect our families and
our communities
but it's not just about returning to a
system that left so many behind
it's about building our nation
back better than before and that's why
joe
is going to make sure that our steps for
economic recovery
are just equitable
and benefit all americans creating
millions of good-paying jobs and he's
going to invest in the small businesses
that are the backbone of our country
and he will not only defend the
affordable care act
he will build on it as well
because it was always meant to be like a
starting point not a finish line
so he's going to create a public health
insurance option like medicare so that
everyone can have high quality
affordable health care plan
and he's going to lower premiums
deductibles and out-of-pocket costs
and the big one i think for everybody
he's going to
make prescription drugs affordable
and i hear that across this country
joe has spent his entire career bringing
people together
and getting this seemingly impossible
done
and i can't think of anyone better that
to lead us through this pandemic
than my husband joe with the chaos of
this moment
the uncertainty it can be easy to watch
you know what's going on and feel so
discouraged i mean i feel
i hear from a lot of people you know how
much anxiety and depression they feel
but right now we don't have to just
watch what happens
we have to decide what happens and when
we elect
joe and kamala they will help bring
us back together and heal our fractured
communities and they have the fortitude
to help us rebuild better than ever
and with their steady leadership
steady not chaos like we have now
we can change the course of our future
so for just a moment i want to take you
to that future
so imagine that it's november 4th
the day after the election i know we're
on like counting down right
you wake up and it's a beautiful morning
maybe
a little bit more sunshine than today
and maybe you stayed up a little
too late watching the returns i'm sure
we're going to be up to all night
so you go and you pour yourself a cup of
coffee
and at first you start to worry about
your day which i'm sure you all do now
like thinking oh my gosh what time are
my meetings what time do i have to get
onto that computer
you know you're thinking about your zoom
schedule
and then it hits you like oh my god joe
biden won the election
[Laughter]
and pretty soon there's going to be a
nationwide strategy to end this pandemic
and when you go out to get your mail you
think about your neighbor who lost her
job and then you realize whoa
the next president is the same man who
led
the recovery in 2008 that created
millions of
jobs you go to check the
the news and you notice there's no pit
in your stomach your shoulders don't
tense up you're not dreading what's
going on
in the world instead you sit
a little taller knowing that our next
commander-in-chief will
bring out the best in us a president and
a vice president-elect
that your kids your granddaughter
can look up to leadership that makes you
proud
joe biden and kamala harris
and for the first time in so
long you take a deep breath
and you feel hope that's the november
4th
that i won and i know it's the november
4th you all want or you wouldn't be
sitting here today
in this moment we have the power to
decide what comes
next so i know you're here because
you're already engaged
and or you wouldn't be sitting in this
freezing cold
and i know you're busy and you're
probably stretched too thin
but i'm asking you to just do a little
bit more for the next 36 days
because this election is just too
important to sit out on the sidelines
all of us have to do every single thing
we can
until the election this is it
there are no do-overs this is our last
shot to wake up november 4th
and feel that hope
so join us go to iwillvote.com to make
sure you're registered
so i don't know if you've all done that
and so to make sure you're registered
help your friends and family do that too
make sure they're registered we have
just
oh and then if you want to get involved
with our campaign
this is so funny you text cheese
to three zero three three zero
it's very fitting so we have just
36 more days 36 more
days to make sure that our voices are
heard
to make calls and talk to our neighbors
to
fight for this country like we've never
fought before
let's wake up november 4th knowing that
we did everything we can to feel that
hope again
this is our moment this is our election
this is our nation and we will get to
choose
our future together
so thank you all for being here thank
you for you know
in this chilly weather thank you for
your commitment and your support
thank you thank you everybody
oh thanks thanks
okay
[Music]
you